Hi, my name is Mark and we're gonna look at small business ideas for going green.
What I mean by green is basically working in an environmentally friendly manner.
Some of the issues we are being faced with daily, in terms of the environmental issues,...
...are the excess amount of paper we use in an office.
So, obviously, if we're using the Internet more and more,...
...we should try and reduce our paper usage.
At the same time, we're using more and more energy...
...when we use our Internet through our computers.
So maybe we should be more efficient with our use of the computer,...
...switching it on and off,...
...the beginning and the end of every day.
Make sure that it's switched off so we're not using the power.
Also, we think about the products that we're using in the office.
For example, if your office has a kitchen, you might be using cleaning detergents.
Well, maybe you could buy cleaning detergents that are packaged in eco-friendly...
...or environmentally friendly cartons.
That could be some form of office policy and imprint...
...from the organization to show that it's going green in that respect.
There are all kinds of things that you can do to reduce the amount of energy you use...
...and consume, and the types of materials you use can be changed as well.
Make sure it's office policy; go green!